yeah there's got to be a bunch of
complications yeah what are some of the
problems that come with it can't all be
amazing there has to be some sometimes
there's got to be something that goes
wrong right what's what's the downside
uh yeah I think the the number one is
the woman wanting the attention from her
man right and when there's so many it's
giving the even-even amount of attention
and then taking it the wrong way or not
listening not hearing what I actually
said and and living together at all sort
of falls in line with time in the month
and so you have a lineup where it was
all four at once that time of the month
so that when you step out and find yeah
what do you do when it is that time of
them because if you got to come five
times a day just crime scene sex it
doesn't matter dude yeah well you still
we still go at it no matter what time of
the month it is or you take a step so it
doesn't matter much to me and let's be
honest you can afford a new set of
sheets every month right big [ __ ]
deal if we get some stains on there
right who cares yeah although that's not
my particular sexual pleasure
I don't enjoy that you know I enjoy most
things but that one I can't do like you
specifically won't do the crime scene
sex sex on period is not for you yeah
and they hate it when they like I want
to have sex at some times I handle it
wrong and I'll say the Lord is punishing
you I can't do it so you got you got to
get it done
what kind of protection do you use
condoms or no one no oh baby
right right cuz why would you right now
do you as part of the deal though
they're on the pill yes to make sure
that they're not because you like to you
hit it wrong you bust inside am i right
what's uh speaking of details
ladies be honest with me tell me what
the Candy Man is packing I would imagine
I would imagine it's got to be
impressive
you know big hands yeah a really
confident so I imagine that a man is
packing good do they sell
if you don't use it you lose it so the
more you use it yeah I know it works
yeah yeah I would
don't you wish though it was like a
micropenis like it's the one thing that
we can relate to just come with me at a
knife not a gun